- C'est pendant la fin de
semaine de Pâques qu'on brasse
les meilleures affaires dans
les chocolateries.
Et pour certains clients,
pas question se restreindre
quand c'est le temps de
se sucrer le bec.
- Je me suis gâtée, j'ai gâté
ma famille. Je me le permets
parce que c'est bon et c'est
une gâterie pour tout le monde.
- Oui j'ai acheté un chien,
on a un chien. On achète
toujours un chien
- Ça vous a coûté combien?
- Je sais pas, une trentaine de
dollars, mais ça vaut la peine.
- Même les animaux en chocolat
sont victimes de l'inflation.
Comme bien d'autres choses,
le prix des pastilles de cacao
a bondi.
EDITH BÉDARD, fondatrice
Pastille, Chocolaterie
- Ça a augmenté d'environ 7%
dans l'année, c'est quand même
énorme. Puis je dirais que c'est
pas le seul défi parce que tout
ce qui est approvisionnement,
non seulement chocolat,
mais tout ce qui est emballage,
c'est des vrais casse-tête,
des fois il y a des pénuries
de choses.
- En affaires depuis deux ans,
Edith Bédard a dû augmenter
ses prix pour une première fois.
- J'ai pas eu le choix, j'avais
pas augmenté depuis le début
de l'ouverture, puis si je le
faisais pas j'allais me faire
rentrer dedans. Donc on fait
ce qu'il faut puis on espère que
les clients soient quand même
au rendez-vous.
- Dans ce magasin de friandises
qui a pignon sur rue depuis
1929, on s'attend à recevoir
jusqu'à 1000 clients par jour
au cours de la fin de semaine.
JULIEN SIMARD, propriétaire
Biscuiterie Oscar
- C'est définitivement la plus
grosse période de l'année pour
nous. C'est vraiment notre
spécialité les chocolats
de Pâques.
- Mais puisque les fournisseurs
ont haussé leurs prix,
la boutique a dû ajuster
les siens en conséquence.
- On regarde à peu près
un 6% d'augmentation
cette année, un 5-6%.
- Malgré tout, Julien Simard
s'attend à réaliser de bonnes
ventes.
- Les gens vont sortir vont
aller voir leur famille, vont se
rencontrer, vont se rassembler,
donc c'est plus propice
à offrir.
- Et il y a du choix pour ceux
qui veulent épater la galerie.
- C'est le plus gros lapin qu'on
a ici, 4,2 kilos, environ
quatre pieds de hauteurs, il se
détaille environ 109,99$,
donc si on a une bonne famille,
c'est parfait pour partager.
- Avis aux intéressés, c'est
le dernier qui reste, tous les
autres ont déjà été vendus.
Ici Olivier Bachand
Radio-Canada, Mon